and where have you come from and how
long have you been waiting here to see
the king and queen we're from crewman's
Somerset I do just have to explain the
booze look just just over on the other
side of the mouth
there are some protesters here who are
holding up signs who voted for him and
not my king and as soon as those signs
go up
quite a few people on the mail are
booing those signs and there's also
somebody
um who is
um obviously a fan of the king that
holds up a banner in front of those
protest battles so just to explain the
booing
um they're protesting quietly but they
hold up those banners every now and
again but obviously the majority here
are in favor of what's going on today
and looking forward to the Celebration